nous vous donnions hier les bons
chiffres du chômage tellement bon que la
pénurie se fait parfois sentir dans
certains secteurs comme l'informatique
ou il manque 35 mille ingénieurs en
france pour pallier ces manques
certaines entreprises n'hésitent pas à
se tourner vers l'inde où les
informaticiens ne manquent pas à des
prix défiant toute concurrence patrick
fandio et frère hector au bout de la
route
un parc futuriste bienvenue dans la
silicon valley asiatiques
nous sommes à bangalore dans le sud de
l'inde dans ces bâtiments flambant neufs
des centaines d'entreprises
la plupart étrangères tout spécialisée
dans les nouvelles technologies de
l'information et tout à la recherche
d'un informaticien locaux ben voilà
c'est la grande salle qui va être
réaménagé plus tard quand on a tout
l'équipe quarantaine on espère les
bureaux sont encore vides
cette filiale indienne d'une start up
française est en pleine croissance
ces ingénieurs développent un célèbre
jeu vidéo sur internet
hyper sophistiqué grâce à leur savoir
faire
la société est leader en europe en un an
et demi d'existence
le chiffre d'affaires a été multiplié
par neuf
comment l'avez-vous depuis paris le
patron et en ligne par vidéoconférence
internet
c'est un chef d'entreprise combler son
équipe indienne lui coûte deux à trois
fois moins cher qu'en france on pas
trouver de travail de qualité
ils sont dépensés trop mais c'est vrai
que maintenant beaucoup de grandes
sociétés viennent ici en ends et les
salaires sont en train de monter
c'est moins cher quand même cette main
d'oeuvre bon marché profite déjà de
nombreuses entreprises sur place
les ingénieurs indiens ont par exemple
fait la fortune du bill gates locale
azim premji l'un des dix hommes les plus
riches du monde
un homme simple qui fuit les médias un
ancien vendeur de savons aujourd'hui
propriétaire d'un empire qui vaut 13
milliards de dollars et emploie 6500
informaticiens ses ingénieurs sont très
qualifiés très brillant très
opérationnelles sont ambitieux quand ils
sont dans des entreprises qui leur donne
de bonnes perspectives et je pense que
les pionniers qui ont construit cette
industrie ici ont beaucoup fait pour
rétablir l'ordre
une réputation de qualité et la qualité
les entreprises étrangères viennent la
chercher ici cette ancienne propriété de
maharaja abrite depuis 1909
l'un des instituts de technologie les
plus réputés au monde la salle que nous
visitons a été gratuitement équipés par
une compagnie américaine
ces étudiants ont déjà tous été recrutés
on leur a fait miroiter stock-options
voitures et logements de fonction les
salaires proposés sont 30 % plus bas
qu'en europe mais c'est encore beau sur
le marché mondial le salaire ne valent
rien
un dollar vu 45 roupies pour un
informaticien étrangers c'est très peu
mais quand vous viviez en rien des
comparé à d'autres pays
une c'est très bien cela préfère rester
ici avec leurs amis et leur famille
beaucoup en revanche s'expatrient plus
d'ailleurs aux états unis qu'en europe
dans la capitale indienne de la
net-économie ans commencent à
s'inquiéter de cette fuite de cerveaux
la pénurie d'informaticiens et mondiale
l'inde en souffrent aussi
il en manque 67000 dans le pays les
grands groupes étrangers risquent de
plus en plus d'être perçues
comme des pilleurs de matière grise